hello and welcome to this video playing
d s eval did he say well yeah you don't
know okay well let's go and maybe I can
try the exchange we haven't and like
that y know stuff that's bad news I
don't know stuff and okay something like
that is a is a line but I don't know
much more than that 96 poof and now he
takes okay and I can certainly play both
90 Swan queen cheeks my queen takes is
the very technical move but it's the
Queens gambit exchange after all oh he
allows me to take their surprising
hmm okay I guess I'll do it guess I'll
do it okay I wouldn't mind to play a
forward my night is somewhat misplaced
for that let's not do it
a4 a5 maybe to secure my night okay well
I don't mind if it takes then then I
basically win the F porn so and it's not
a big deal jack yeah g3 I guess ok I
think now I probably check and go H
forms and now 93 to f5 and looks good
osf for too early if I go F for here you
might have that counterplay route g8 but
I can play a look G 10 km and it's not a
problem
check yeah shooting for g4 next Jack
very sitting on that ugly double porn or
two of them but especially the f double
pond is a big problem okay so how to do
this night III is not so ideal okay i
think i have to probably get the edge
porn going
hmm
once to defend with 97 it seems ok so I
wanted to get the night to c5 that was
my grand plan here
it's not doing much about it and he's
doing nothing about it at all so does he
really just want to play rugby eight now
and play this position that's hard to
believe okay but let's not be too quick
about it I want to go with give i can go
d 4 immediately actually i don't have to
place you three years is kind of
important i had 97 actually that would
have been strong i should think more
concretely made d 4 is good
strategically but let this happen just
picks up sit ups up picks up f6 and the
game yeah still and it still does it's
even a little bit more awkward as that
gives us a check on f6 check
q
check so how to do it now check one
check
you
yeah you porn will decide the decide the
day check Jack Black resigns yeah I've
got a nice end game here out of the
exchange he played that trade on f3 that
is somewhat accommodating I guess and
not necessary yet I think they mostly do
this but I cannot really not really tell
for sure yeah I'm okay well and this is
definitely comfortable yeah and he
allowed me to to double his pawns this
is not super clear how bad it is but I'm
not quite sure why he wanted to do it
okay I made a couple of a normal moose a
45 to freeze the Queen side a little bit
and check ya hear I'm of course I'm
happy with those developments him I
control f5 and I have f4 installment I
went for it okay okay the engine has a
very good solution as usual or an
interesting solution it wants to hear
and I saw that fund I thought okay that
NK must be great but the engine gives
this and this is interesting it doesn't
help the way i can go King f2 and if i
go here he's got 95 that's interesting
but it was too much but i could just
bring the King up and
still better so here check yeah that was
happy with that now I just basically
play with an extra edge back but you
still have to have to convert what the
King round yeah now I had this idea with
putting the night over on the on c5 and
he never I've never really fought that
idea I think at least here you should go
be six and then I have to reconsider
maybe just deform go from there then
maybe later here here to pressurize
those two booty I'm winning and I'll
just 97 of course fire that was the
strategic idea here always d for this is
why I went for it but 97 was of course
just ending ending the game right yeah
there was a decent game I think thanks
for watching